flippy from
indiana flippy from indiana please
unmute you are on the air my friend
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh earnings season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
[Music]
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh
five and a quarter
[Music]
oh boy let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy
let's remind you
[Music]
a sound of victory
a sound of victory
[Music]
i hear a sound of victory
david jones is his running mate the most
liberal senator in america
kamala
senator kamala harris
democrat kamala
[Music]
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease
diabetes breast cancer their common fear
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you thank
you
coming for you if you are under the age
senator
[Music]
i want to just first of all say i'm so
excited to be here
thank you thank you thank you there is
so much about what comes out of donald
trump's mouth
don't be rude in the name of jesus from
south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
[Music]
winning winning all right welcome
everybody um i i would just keep playing
songs but
i i actually am here and we do have so
many things to get to today that i don't
want to waste
i want to waste some time but not
like just indefinite time wastage we're
not going to do that we're standing by
for
gensaki we've we've determined
i first was saying saki people corrected
me i went to saki then people said it's
sake i went back to saki correction
i listened to her say it yesterday it's
sake
and that's the way i'm going to be
pronouncing it okay so we're standing by
for a white house press briefing
expecting all sorts of nasty questions
and um it will be um
at the bottom of the hour okay so we're
standing by for
that and i have so many things to go
over with you guys now i do want to just
mention
for people who aren't following this
closely
coronavirus cases are falling off a
cliff and that's good news now i know
everybody wants to
wants to uh uh sow uh what we call
fud fear uncertainty and doubt any day
it's going to explode and everything's
terrible forever but things actually are
improving significantly the vaccines
appear
moderately to very effective against the
variant we're down about 70 percent
the peak was january 11th where we were
averaging over 255
000 cases a day we are all the way down
to 82
000 cases a day uh and
that is i think that that's that being
down about
70 i believe uh should we
should we pull out the calc let's do it
so we were at 255
and now we're down to 82 about 68
okay so that's good deaths of course
take longer to decline but
also declining that was a peak of about
four hundred
we're down to twenty two seventy that's
almost a
thirty ish percent decline so these are
all
good things these are all good things
vaccinations also
doubling since joe biden took over if
you look at january 19th
20th the end of trump's presidency about
900
000 doses a day we are now all the way
up to 1.7
million and we had a couple days
yesterday was actually the best day in
terms of uh vaccines there is this
outlier day here
but that's because there were no reports
for multiple days before this is a
combination of the prior three days
this seems yesterday of all the days
yesterday
seems to have been the best day for
vaccinations
2.3 million and that is a
a very very good thing um and we are
going to continue
following that as well as so many other
things that we are following the cuomo
scandal people are asking me about
i've addressed that on the bonus show we
talked about it extensively yesterday
so i won't go over it again but if you
are a member
hello you can see that discussion
i have no problem criticizing cuomo i
don't care if people are republicans or
democrats
um and the allegations against cuomo are
serious
are serious all right uh do you think
part of the reason people like mcconnell
cruz hawley don't seem to care about
their legacy is because they're in
actuality nihilists uh i don't know
about them
i'd have to think about that thomas says
love from the uk
danny says what's so urgent about this
press meeting that it needs
caps david save it for the things that
are actually urgent makes you look like
a thirst trap
nothing's really urgent it's just a joke
it's just it's not a big deal you know
we don't need to go crazy
it's um it's just a joke it's okay
all right i have some clips planned
i have some unban requests to adjudicate
i may play voicemails i'm actually going
to put it to a vote
um and i don't even know where to go
next well actually
let's let's start here um
let's take a look at this this
is the new fabricated scandal
fox news now is desperate why are why is
fox news desperate fox news is desperate
because
they weren't pro-trump enough in the
aftermath of the election to keep their
whole audience so a bunch of viewers
went to oan and newsmax
at the same time biden's the most
popular
president in his first month in 28 years
so fox is like wait do we go crazy
pro-trump again are we going to
criticize biden people like what biden's
doing so what about
they don't know what to do so they have
now gone back to
the equivalent of obama's tan suit here
is the new scandal
which is that jill and joe biden don't
really love each other that much it's a
stage
managed public relations sham
okay this is the new scandal it's sort
of like the new war on christmas take a
look
at the heart of this great american
family is a love story one man
one woman in the fires of passion that
changed the course of our history
not since anthony dine with cleopatra in
downtown antioch before they killed
themselves obviously
has a country witnessed a love story as
moving and poignant as
jill and joe's no ladies and gentlemen
jill biden is not
joe's caretaker she isn't his nurse
she's his fully equal romantic
partner so that's an allusion to joe
biden dementia that he throws in there
whether they are like besotted teens yet
at the same time they are the wise and
knowing parents of a nation as a
headline from politico on valentine's
day put it quote
historians and relationship experts
agree
the first couple's romantic gestures
aren't just genuine
they're restorative so it's official the
biden's affection is totally real it's
in no way part of a slick pr campaign
devised by cynical consultants
determined to hide the president's
senility by misdirection
not at all there's the senility thing
again
their love is as real as climate change
and then there is of course tucker
carlson suggesting that climate change
also is imaginary so
i can't imagine anyone's really going to
care about this
it's funny how desperate fox news is at
this point in time
um it is uh it's it's just uh
it's just incredible that this is their
this is their new thing okay
so that's that and then also we looked
at this yesterday but today
having had a chance to put together a
segment on it i looked at it more
closely
here is tucker also claiming that wind
power and the green energy is the reason
for what's going on in texas good
evening
welcome to tucker carlson tonight happy
monday well the green new deal has come
believe it or not to the state of texas
and we're here with the report how's it
working out so far well the good news is
all that alternative energy seems to
have had a remarkable effect on the
climate as
intended last night parts of texas
got to temperatures that we see in
alaska in fact they were the same as
they were in alaska
so global warming is no longer a
pressing concern in houston
we've so that's the um that's the false
notion that
you know climate change predicts that
the world on average may warm
but you will have many highs and lows in
places
and climates nothing has been disproven
because it's cold in texas
of that problem the bad news is they
don't have electricity
the windmills froze so the power grid
failed okay and of course
most of the energy most of the energy
that texas gets
isn't from wind power and most of the
failures
were actually nuclear coal and natural
gas plants that were not
winterized and now having had more time
to research this since yesterday we know
that in 2011 there was a similar problem
a decade ago in texas
there's a report pages and pages just
massive dumps of data
saying here's how to prevent this from
happening again they didn't do any of
that stuff
so sadly it's the failure of texas
leadership
here is greg abbott pulling the same
thing what good is it
so this shows how the green new deal
would be a deadly deal for the united
states of america
why what why what are you talking about
the the green new deal has nothing to do
with this
so there's greg abbott and then here is
fox and friends this morning pulling
much the same thing
blaming wind farms but he said for the
first time he's seeing a little bit of
california now
with what happened with the weather and
the wind turbines what happened with the
wind turbines
yeah some wind turbines froze because
they weren't winterized
but the main problem was that nuclear
natural gas and coal energy generation
was taken offline because the
instruments were not winterized that's
really the problem
so there there it looks like you know we
say this is not the hill to die on
it looks like they're determined to go
down on this hill they're willing to die
on this hill
and um it is we have a
extensive report on the podcast which i
filmed which will be out at 3 30 p.m
eastern time um if you want to go deeper
on this issue
we've already recorded it you can get
get that free podcast subscription
itunes stitcher all that stuff and we we
do a full segment about it so they're
continuing to do that
we have learned that uh radical
right-wing radio host rush limbaugh has
died presumably of the lung cancer that
we learned he was suffering from about a
year ago
as i mentioned before i can recognize
that
um someone is terrible for the world
without wishing for their illness or
death or taking pleasure in it
and rush limbaugh has died
i have long said that this was a
absolutely terrible person in terms of
their influence on the world but
our condolences to his loved ones and
families
because i would never wish death or
illness upon everybody but that is the
news
david what's your take on the
spontaneous trump rally on president's
day p.s it was planned yeah we talked
talked about it on on to yesterday's
bonus show
no yesterday's regular show tucker
should be sued again oh he will be
the wind turbines could have been
winterized as well but republicans
skipped on that just like the water
lines for the rest of the power grid
exactly alex exactly david you're a bit
quiet today on your end oh i'm sorry
about that
let's see what i can do um
nothing's changed maybe i'll just go up
one
one click here let me see
i just went up one element of audio
okay very good have you heard about gb
news
being launched in the uk soon dubbed the
british version of fox news i have not
heard of that
no rush limbaugh passed away limbaugh
died
yes we have heard of that
okay all right we have already dealt
with that
i want to say thank you to the
11 folks who just grabbed twitch subs
including a gift of five from ky
dizzle as well as a bunch of other
people very much appreciate that
and uh we will be very very closely
tracking
website members here you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and my promise to you
today
to the people is that i will thank
everybody who grabs a membership
at joinpackman.com okay
do people want me to play a couple of
troy york voicemails i am going to paste
a poll into the chat on twitch
as well as on youtube every time i do
this
if i don't play them people write to me
and say david you gotta play those troy
york voicemails
when i do play them some people say
don't do it
okay so let's take a look at what the
people want i will go by what the people
want and take myself out of this
completely
okay uh we've pasted the link i'm sorry
for people on facebook i have no easy
way of pasting
it um but we are going to take a look
here and see
i have a bunch of troy york voicemails
if people want them i will play them if
people decide no then i am going to skip
them this is democracy
um 200 people have voted beautiful
uh so far by about a two to one ratio
the yeses
have it uh continuing to be about a two
to one ratio
some people angry some people happy a
lot of different things this is not
fake populism or anything like it
i am just going to the people i want to
hear from the people
with about 320 330 votes it remains
about a two to one margin
uh at this point in time there are about
seven thousand eight thousand people
watching in total so only a fraction
this is the problem with democracy it is
reflective only of the people who choose
to participate
and uh of the seven thousand people
eight thousand watching only
377 have as of yet weighed in i guess
i can assume that means most people
don't care
interesting people are asking about why
there hasn't been hatred mail for a
while there actually is a reason
and it came on the advice of federal
authorities that's not a joke and that's
maybe a story i will tell some way
someday but there is there is a very
specific reason why there has not been
hatred mail recently
okay i am going to call it over a two to
one margin people want to hear a little
bit of these troy york voicemails
let's just listen to them real quick we
don't have to go crazy
um here he is praising ron desantis
as well i'll say that i'm glad that we
republicans we need to back
men like ron desantis i think that he
has got great candy potential in 2024
i'd like i'd love to see ronda sanders
jim jordan ticket
um basically trump can still uh
work with them both trumps i think the
trump family has a strong future
in uh politics and the republican party
so this was just boring it's not it's
not even remotely interesting
and then here were some um i think let
me see if this was troy as well
mr pacman oh no that's a different guy
so i guess i only have the one troy york
yeah i know i thought i had more
tucker call yeah no i so that's the only
one all right the people have voted and
we've got
that all right very good um
vivid elites sends a super chat saying
i'm ignoring david's request for us to
participate in his democracy
and instead participating in his
capitalism
oh okay wow so there is that
and let me now adjudicate some unbanned
requests
uh as a reminder um on twitch there's a
mechanism where if you get
ban hammered you can then submit a
request
to be unbanned and then i can adjudicate
it
on uh on stream now a few people
posted yesterday on the um
guys we know rush limbaugh died i
already talked about it there's not
there's really nothing else to say he
died and you know
we send our condolences to his family
people were saying i should get a
a gavel for when i adjudicate unban
requests the problem is if i got a
wooden gavel
there's really nothing i mean i don't
wanna i risk shaking the equipment if
i'm slamming a wooden gavel
the other alternative would be to get a
um one
almost like a uh like a squeeze toy
gavel
i just don't know if that would be as
interesting okay so let's go through
here is a user
who has sent more than a hundred
messages on the channel
most recently let's see what they said
i thought the stream was in three hours
i'm overseas who is this dude looks like
ron paul but no accent
i think they're talking about me hello
green man
green man i am here for you green man
it's from discord green man
green man oh okay so they were harassing
one of our moderators green man
and then green man banned them their
unban request is i am too poor for super
chats
so i got myself banned to ask you
when you are going to create an only
fans oh my god
so that was a that's a clever way of
getting me to address it so that's
clever
that's a pretty clever way to get
actually without a super chat me to
answer their question
for creativity i am going to grant an
unban on that
that's pretty good that's pretty good um
okay and then here is another one
this person got banned
they came in yesterday oh this is a
fresh one they came in yesterday
why is the left always censoring free
speech why is the radical left always
censoring
free speech why is the radical left
always censoring free speech and then
they were banned
and then as their unbanned uh plea
they say i was merely expressing my
concern
about the left's tendency to censor free
speech
and i got banned for it one might
consider this censorship the tolerant
left curious
no you were banned because you spammed
the same message multiple times in three
minutes
but you know what i am benevolent i
sometimes see a ban sort of like as a
time out
for really childish folks so i am going
to grant the unban
that doesn't mean the moderators were
wrong in doing it at the time
it just means that i think it's okay to
do an unban now
and if they need to be banned again then
they'll get banned again it's as simple
as that i am not here to try to keep
people banned
for some you know weird reason that's
not my not my priority
uh okay very good so we've gotten that
out of the way
and we are now just a few minutes from
the start of this
press briefing the perfunctory message
is that the
coupon code isn't working okay
uh i i can assure you that it is
i will even test it right now for you
it is not case sensitive every time this
happens somebody says david you should
really explain that it's case sensitive
it's like
it's not case sensitive okay sign up
however you want join pacman.com
sign up button all right 60
a year the normal price you don't have
to pay that coupon code
better 21. okay we click
off 211. guys it's right there
it works it works it works it works i'll
even prove to you it's not case
sensitive here's the six dollar a month
membership coupon code
caps better 21 all caps
and it works it's not case sensitive
guys come on
come on man it's working fine
it's working fine okay
um oh and i do want to thanks say thanks
to dranoa for
13 months at tier one
new credor and a whole bunch of other
people
uh in fact five people putting us
at 14 and
don't worry i will thank everybody
who signs up at joinedpakman.com
i should definitely get a squeeze toy
gavel that squeaks
i will send a 50 dollar super chat if
you do i didn't see
a squeeze toy gavel that squeaks i saw
just like
a you know like a stress ball
gavel but i did not see one that squeaks
david did you cover the joe biden town
hall event no i didn't because
i was warned both twitch and youtube
were likely to
uh see cnn shut me down and it was just
too great a risk
so no i did not cover the town hall
because i would have gotten
uh i would have gotten ban hammered sam
says stuck at home due to texas weather
thanks for the stream to help entertain
me
while i work on my preliminary exam exam
slides my pleasure
my pleasure please tell us the story
about hatred mail
maybe someday maybe someday i don't know
about that
turn your volume up i did i think we're
doing fine now on volume
maybe i'll just put the mic a little
closer to me also
there we go testing testing one two
mike pillow about to get massive dumps
of dominion lawsuits
please pray for him yeah
don't know if you already talked about
this what's your take on the governor of
texas going on fox and blaming the green
new deal
we did talk about that in fact i played
the clip which is right here
and i've got a segment on today's
podcast so i won't i won't do it again
because we we did address that
tristan says i got into a mild fight on
chat before and feel embarrassed
i wish to atone i love all my pacman
brothers and sisters thanks tristan
what's my favorite movie i i don't have
just one
i don't know um
people asking if i read twitch chat yes
i do
that's always uh always mentioned
and yes the answer is yes i do when is
gnome
chompski chomsky is his last name when
is known chomsky going to be on the show
it's scheduled for march i don't want to
say too much because often times these
high
profile guests they end up having to
reschedule or whatever
he's scheduled for um he's scheduled for
march
and very very hopeful that it's going to
happen i think it'll be a great
interview
it'll be great great interview and there
will be many many things discussed
jacob asking my thoughts on rush
limbaugh passing away already addressed
it
i think rush limbaugh was terrible for
the country and for the world one of the
most negative influences in media
that i can think of but i don't wish
illness on anyone
nor death and we send condolences to his
family and everybody who
cared about him deepak favorite con
condiments of choice for frankfurters
well first of all as many of you know i
don't eat pork so i am
always dealing with a uh an all-beef hot
dog always must be an
all-beef hot dog i don't want it um
what would be the word for like it what
there's a particular word
i don't want i don't want to say tainted
i want unadulterated beef okay let's put
it that way
and uh i'm a must mustard and relish
mustard and relish for me i couldn't
work out how to vote sorry we'll try
harder next time
since new york city is a ghost town i
decided to leave my beloved home upon
getting caught up in two hour traffic
just to exit the city i realized we are
in fact
not a ghost town so i decided to stay
what is a movie you like a lot
you know the first movie i ever saw when
we moved to the united states and we got
a vcr
i remember that i was allowed as the
older of the
of the children i was allowed to choose
our first
rental vhs tape knowing nothing about
the acting bonafides of michael keaton
nor
jack nicholson i chose batman
the original and to this day i still can
sit down and watch that movie anytime i
love that movie
really really good movie just try to
join if you enter the code
first it applies but if i fill out my
info
then the code it hangs code first people
that shouldn't happen that may be a vpn
thing
that may be a vpn thing but i do want to
say thank you to
brian wenkel for signing up at
joinpacman.com
manfredshear frank
adams cortes warren
guy and rachel letney all of whom just
signed up at joinpackman.com
very much appreciate that very much
appreciate that
steven says found out i have skin cancer
today
caught early make sure you don't skip
your dermatologist appointment
fuji apples are the best tacos are a
sandwich
i'm really sorry to hear that steven uh
i i know that
early skin cancer is often uh it's an
almost perfect prognosis and i hope that
that's your case
and uh get well soon very sorry to hear
that
uh but i can't allow you to get through
nonsense like fuji apples granny smith
apples are the best
and tacos are absolutely not
a sandwich not a sandwich
have i watched shit's creek yet no my
girlfriend's watched it i've just never
gotten into it
you know here's a here's a beautiful
story guys
um last night i was watching
season two of the amazon original bosh
now this is not like the best show now
it's not vosh
the streamer the guy we know is chris
it's not vosh
it's bosh and in season two
the actress jerry ryan appears
moments after finishing the episode
i went on twitter and looked at my blue
checkmark feed and
actress jerry ryan liked and retweeted
one of my tweets yesterday
right okay
people don't care fine
um love to the skin cancer guy
absolutely
absolutely james says any favorite
seinfeld episodes
when i listened to you years ago you and
pat were discussing watching seinfeld
and how much you enjoyed it no i mean
the marble rye episode i think is really
good
almost every episode is fantastic the
one where
kramer pretends to be a dermatologist dr
van nostrand
i believe is the name that he uses i
love that that's a great
episode um what are other episodes i
really like
there's just so many soup nazi of course
uh
the one with the scene about car
reservations
where jerry tries to rent a car and
they're like we don't have the car and
jerry asks if they have the reservation
they're like oh we have the reservation
we don't have the car
and jerry points out that you know
anybody can just take reservations the
key thing is holding it and having a car
that's a good one um
there's just so many yeah it's it's it's
just unbelievable
what was i doing in stock guys stream
yeah earlier when i was having lunch a
lot of viewers
told me that stock guy is
um is a interesting channel
so i just checked it out and i was in
the chat and somebody gifted me
a um a subscription on twitch to the
stock guy
which was great loved it
few other thank yous robert cantor has
signed up at joinpakman.com
ahmad al hatham haitham
has signed up i hope i pronounced that
correctly
ilka rosa is a new member sean gorton
has signed up
and so has sean stone a lot of a lot of
sean activity
and i also want to say thanks to the
eight additional
subscribers on twitch who just signed up
appreciate you guys people like
flurries who just gifted some subs and
harassed ottle draco
dracaj hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
oh yeah the chicken episode where the
chicken place has that red neon light
outside kramer's apartment
and kramer and jerry sort of like switch
personalities after switching apartments
that's a good one
that's a good one and anything with uh
anything with jerry stiller is great
people asking what's next we're just
standing by for a white house press
briefing
any moment now expecting it to start uh
let's make sure we are in hd
always the best for you guys
any moment expecting this to start
all right other super chats coming in
miss my previous super chat says
eugene okay let's see david have you
looked at into the accused impeachment
evidence falsification
blue checkmark and date on tweets from
jennifer lin let me know i have not
i have not any thoughts on the clubhouse
app
i really don't know anything about it
i've never uh no
have i seen the tv show black sales no
frasier is better than seinfeld that is
the type of take that will get you
banned
that'll get you that's going to be a
that could be a ban hammer
do i still think biden should expand the
supreme court sure
sure tino says i missed tino's question
let's see
does the fact that the republican party
is fracturing due to trump
evidence of accelerationism working
no definitely not definitely not
rush limbaugh is dead he contributed to
the disinformation
campaign that poisoned the minds of many
that's true and we send condolences to
anybody who
uh cared about him your followers have
failed to not know jerry ryan
that's a double negative right failed to
so they know jerry
is that right we need an in-depth update
on stimulus
please extensive conversation on
yesterday's bonus show about that
big big big time conversation there have
i sold my bitcoin
no no bitcoin now
at 51 000
it's nuts what's going on btc usd
wow that's a wowza
if i've ever seen one um
let's look at where things are so i've
been
in bitcoin since about 4 500
right around here
i believe my average cost of ownership
is about 4 500 per coin
so yeah i sold 15 on january 1st and
obviously i regret that because let's
see where is january 1st
here's january 1st and you know it's up
70
since then so i'm just holding
it's it's speculative obviously and
uh i uh you know i i'm not advocating
anybody do anything
i'm just i'm just holding i sold 15
of it january 1st and then otherwise i'm
holding
4 500 yes 4 500 was my uh
entry point so to speak
yeah it's almost like dollar cost
averaging out in a sense
i don't pretend to know anything i
pretend to know nothing
sending love from alaska thanks for
being wonderful david love from india
thank you david please pop into your
discord the general chat is always good
notice us senpai
i'm in the discord every day i go into
the discord usually around
9 00 am east i will go into the discord
i'll see what's happening in all of the
different
moderator um channels
and then i will look at any uh mentions
and then i will look at some of the
memes and some of the general and then
i'm out
everybody asking about rush limbaugh
passing we've already addressed it on
the show
twice so i'm not i'm not going to keep
going back but you can go back
if you're interested frasier is far
superior superior to seinfeld i doubt
you'll ban me jerry ryan played seven of
nine
in star trek voyager i don't know
anything about star trek so that i
wouldn't know
a frasier is not superior to seinfeld
there that's
uh that's a weaponized claim
i would call that completely weaponized
few other people to thank thanks to doug
rollins for signing up on my website
thanks to shira do rica for signing up
at joinedpakman.com chris houston
is a new member and rodolfo
sawaim sewame is also
a new member very much appreciate that
um okay yeah people are shot out of a
cannon over the seinfeld claims i agree
i totally agree not uh
no doubt about it what's my goal for
being on twitch
it's kind of a weird question to build
an audience right i mean what
what's the i don't know what what what
what possibility give me like a
i feel like it needs to be a multiple
choice question the immediate goal is to
get to 80
000 followers we're 300 away i guess my
that's my goal in the next half hour can
we get to 80 000 followers i don't know
um says i told my mom about rush
limbaugh dying and she laughed
yeah that that's never been my thing you
know
um personality my constitution is not
such that i would uh
laugh at people dying but i recognized
that the world
was negatively influenced by
uh by rush limbaugh a lot of people
saying
curb is better than seinfeld that is a
that's a more reasonable claim
curb is seinfeld unfettered
and able to be more adult because it's
on hbo
that's that's the truth that's the truth
david any thoughts on biden's foreign
policy dealing with the king of saudi
arabia instead of mbs i
i'm not going to prejudge it i think
it's interesting and so far
i like what i'm hearing from biden on
saudi policy
no doubt that republicans are blaming
clean energy for the power outage in
texas
no justin kozuk would you
invite brian tyler cohen on your show
sure anytime
what's your favorite musical west side
story is mine i'm not really a musical
guy not a musical theater guy
i like a lot of other things love going
to classical music
tanglewood what a great place but not a
big
not a big musical guy have i listened to
left british radio host james o'brien
clips on youtube
great debate style i don't think i have
seeing all these frasier is better than
seinfeld messages all i can say is
serenity now
the office is better than everything
else i haven't ever seen
a single full episode of the office can
you imagine
can you imagine ajensaki is running late
we are standing by for jen saki let me
see if i can find
a shot of the room anybody live in the
room do you guys know
jensaki live
see what we've got here
fox news has rescheduled it for 1 p.m
that's injured that may be the case in
that case we just have a little more
time together than we thought which is
great
okay so we'll see are people asking
about jimmy from
philly yeah jimmy we really haven't
heard much from jimmy from philly lately
i can grab
his latest voicemails which he's been
having a lot of legal trouble
and maybe even substance trouble
um but he left a couple of messages
about eight days ago
let's see here here's one david give me
some philly
white yeah yeah i heard you at the end
of the stream today uh
uh yeah we've been together for four and
a half hours
and long you tapped out for at least two
hours david stop lying
so there was he was weighing in on that
and then this other one david
jimmy from philly white uh i noticed
that you
ran like a little [ __ ] claiming that
you're gonna go work on your show when
uh david shone started talking
what's the matter you can't refuse him
david
uh oh man so that's the last we've heard
from jimmy from philly and that was
that was uh eight days ago i don't know
what else to make of it that's basically
it
that's basically it okay a couple of
other things that i had for you guys
uh where is this oh hold on a second
let me pull this up i had a few things i
was
theoretically going to save them for
tomorrow during the game stop streams
um you guys have oh here it is
you guys have to see the stuff that fox
news has been posting lately
check out like check out some of these
things
victor davis hansen takes on cancel
culture by the way
who is this guy victor davis
hanson let's see who he is oh hoover
institution okay
tells me everything i need to know
hoover institution
uh he was weighing in on cancel culture
very important issue
fox and friends very important issue new
york city school
asks parents to review white identities
don't even know what that means
that's that's odd um
okay that one we covered
uh where were the other ones ah here we
go former seattle business owner on why
he left the city
like you don't even have to see this to
know that this is one of those segments
to talk about how
l democrat quote democrat run cities
are terrible and everybody's abandoning
them and all that stuff
fox really is in shambles they don't
know what to do
here's another one la inspector
dances after shutting down brewery
wow wow what an explosive story i would
even argue that antifur
is somehow involved in that one um and
then let's see if we've got any others
no those are the main i mean just crazy
crazy stuff
really crazy stuff um we could look at a
few
joe biden town hall things let's see
where is the start here it is
um okay so a bunch of people laughing at
joe biden
because he said i like kids better than
people it's like that's an obvious joke
okay
hey folks how are you
how are you good to be back man yes nice
to see you sir
and you know you enjoy being home with a
baby more not only here though
i do yes yeah he's nine and a half
months so i'm very happy no
no everybody knows i like kids better
than people i saw a picture of you with
your grant
the uh the oh joe biden's a pedophile
people went crazy after he said that
um okay vaccine we've talked about
already
joe biden offers to personally help a
mom obtain a vaccine
i can make recommendations and for
federal programs i can do that
as president united states but i can't
tell the state you must
move such and such a group of people up
but here's what i'd like to do wow joe
biden
accurately understanding the limits of
presidential power
i'll stay around after this is over and
maybe we can talk a few minutes and
see if i can get you some help so that's
cool i mean listen there's no doubt that
joe biden is extraordinarily empathetic
having to ask the president to help with
a vaccination obviously
that's not policy that's not policy that
that would be my only criticism but
there's no doubt that he's an empathetic
guy
um joe biden said vaccinate teachers
talks to a little girl about not being
worried about the virus uh
believes the pandemic will wind down by
christmas
refers to trump as the former guy
um which ones are the
oh okay here he said he's sick of tire
talking about trump
what would the president do and i don't
want to pick on the press i shouldn't
i don't i'm tired of talking about
donald trump don't want to talk about
him anymore but
i like the way this guy removes his
glasses the guy on the left did you guys
notice that
what would the president do and i don't
want to pick on the press i shouldn't
i don't i'm tired of talking about
donald trump don't want to talk about
that it's pretty smooth i like that
um okay same thing when he's asked about
the impeachment trial
here's a position on the war on drugs
that many viewers found interesting
police is discussed as an option for
reforming policing
however there are communities where
people live in fear
not of the police but in fear of the
violent gangs who commit crimes
in those neighborhoods how can we be
sure that we don't
over legislate police officers so that
they can't do their job
to protect the law-abiding citizens who
live in these high crime neighborhoods
and yet train officers to police with
compassion
by number one not defunding the police
we have to put more money in wait a
second wait a second
wait a second wasn't every republican
and trump saying biden wanted to re
defund the police
oh right but we knew it was a lie then
yeah obviously we work
so we have legitimate community policing
and we're in a situation where
we change the legislation no one should
go to jail
for a drug offense no one should go to
jail for the use of a drug
they should go to drug rehabilitation
drug rehabilitation all right but now
you got to actually make it happen right
um okay other stuff on police
oh uh this was kind of funny again a
bunch of people criticizing joe biden
for this
i thought it was more funny than
anything else let's take a listen
i'm going to say something's going to
get me in trouble which couldn't go
through a whole show without doing that
and that is that think about it if you
want to know where the american public
is look at the money being spent on
advertising
did you ever five years ago think every
second or third ad out of five or six
you turn on would be biracial couples
no no i'm not i'm not paying for c the
reason i'm so hopeful
is this new generation so i get you know
the point he's trying to make is that
you can
you can see the liberalized
social attitudes reflected in
advertising which is a very
it's an interesting point and it's
studied academically of course
but it it's just fun the way he worded
it was just sort of
weird they're not like us they're
thinking differently
they're more open and we got to take
advantage of it
[Laughter]
i don't know something about that that
just cracks me up um
okay one other one here uh biden started
getting a little too close
to anderson cooper but he fortunately
caught himself and kept the six feet of
distance
hispanics there are people who came on
the visa was able to buy a ticket to get
in the plane and then go home
they didn't come across the rio grande
and swimming excuse me
and and sorry
that's the irishman
[Laughter]
i don't know why this stuff absolutely
cracks me up there's just something
about it
uh joe biden called white supremacist
demented which was welcome
but at the same time the criticism would
be it's
demented suggests that it's merely
people suffering
from from dementia when really we're
talking about a hateful ideology these
groups
you may remember in one of my debates
with the former president
i asked him to condemn the proud boys he
wouldn't do it he said stand by
stand ready or whatever the phrase
exactly was it
is a bane on our existence
it has always been as lincoln said we
have to appeal to our better angels
and these guys are not and women are in
fact
demented they are dangerous people so i
i like the
i like the the the sentiment um
i don't know uh you know if saying that
it's merely dementia
is the right thing to do i think that
that's potentially problematic but um
that was joe biden yesterday at the town
hall very interesting town hall
as we stand by for biden press secretary
jen
saki who will be answering any number of
different questions would be my guess
thank you to martin say who has just
signed up at joinedpakman.com
really appreciate the support martin
thank you so much
also want to say thanks to astrolycos
for gifting a bunch of subs and in fact
a few other people also signed up on
twitch
seven in total putting us at 44.
i have a few other super chats to read
please watch the short video i'm from
marjory taylor green's district and
would like to say
something i saw that video yeah maybe
we'll look at it together at some point
check twitter feed what happened to
military children
at tripler medical in hawaii by usa
government thank you one voice their
story okay i'd have to look at that
off air first to see if it's suitable
for the show
hi i'm a fan from sweden love seinfeld
and your show thanks kenneth very much
appreciate that
dan says i love your show and i like the
improved graphics but i can't help
notice the uk
is missing off the rotating globe behind
you
did we do something wrong what does that
mean is missing
oh wow it is oh that's interesting the
entire british isles are just missing
they've been erased
we're gonna have to talk about that
wow hold on
oh i think there might actually be a dot
there that's very interesting
i didn't even that we're gonna have to
see what happened with that i can't take
credit for it
but we will um oh boy we will see
well hold on is new zealand even on this
map let's see
oh i can't quite tell oh it is oh my god
new zealand is there
okay all right i'll look into that i can
look into that ed says would i invite
farron cousins to the show yeah maybe
veron's a friend uh you know
i would love to uh do something together
let's not mock those who are unstable
jerry seinfeld isn't funny fight me
i'm a member and now i learned you
haven't seen the office and i'm
reconsidering
yikes yikes that's aggressive
that's very very aggressive aaron says
rush limbaugh died yes
we've discussed it two or maybe even
three times so far on the show
uh i know and we have um
we we have addressed it already and
maybe we will have a segment about it
on tomorrow's program i don't know but
yes
i am aware of that have i read about the
situation with the fred meyer grocer in
portland oregon
super messed up no i haven't
reaction mass says japan is missing from
the graphic and it irks me
japan's missing let me see
huh yeah it appears to be missing too
i think this is a simplification um
[Music]
wow i'm gonna have to look into that i
really don't have an explanation
did i see what biden said about uyghurs
last night oh i skipped over that clip
but let's take a look at it
i'm glad to look at that let me see uh
i know i scrolled by it where was the
question
about uyghurs
um pandemic
huh where was that
i'm not now i don't know if i have a
clip here
pandemic former guy
not that one tired of trump
impeachment drug offenses police
bi-racial couples consensus
white supremacy former presidents oh i
don't have that clip
i i'd have to find the clip i don't have
it in front of me
but it is an important issue and uh
i i would be interested in in finding
out more about exactly what he said
uh gbu arthos wants to know does twitch
donations not go towards super chat
no so the super chat so over on the left
that's super chat that's from youtube
twitch stuff is up there up there in the
vertical blue
okay super chat and twitch have nothing
to do with each other
now i've been doing this long enough to
be able to infer
that i think you're asking a different
question when you say
does twitch stuff go to super chat what
i think you mean is do twitch subs count
in this blue bar
i don't know why i think i actually know
what the person means
and the answer is yes yes this blue bar
is website memberships and twitch subs
we did talk about the colorado city
mayor
uh who resigned on today's bonus show uh
talked about that
we did discuss that that's quite a wacky
story and the guy
seems uh not like someone i would want
at my house
for uh for passover let me let me put it
that way
i don't know how else to uh how else to
say it
um i donated just
asking yay or nay to pineapple on pizza
via twitch donation oh my god i'm sorry
i missed that
i used to like pineapple on pizza when i
ate
pork and pork related products since i
don't
i don't really understand the point of
pineapple on pizza i'm not aware of any
other combination that doesn't involve
like canadian bacon for example
where you need pineapple on pizza so i'm
fine with it i don't think
it should be made illegal but i am not
having any a pineapple on pizza
at this point in time did biden address
student loan forgiveness
at the town hall uh that's a good
question did he
loan doesn't appear so
no it doesn't appear that he did uh i i
didn't watch the entire thing i
basically just watched clips today um
pineapple and cheese pizza does
not seem good that does not seem good
i'm not gonna lie that is not appealing
to me i'm seeing people
notifying me that rush limbaugh has died
yes yes if you're just joining us
we've just discussed that a number of
times rush limbaugh died
oh biden talked about ten thousand okay
let's look for that i actually want to
see that
biden student loan let's see if we can
find a clip about that
here it is my family friends and fellow
americans
me too the american dream is to succeed
but how can we fulfill that dream when
debt is many people's only option for a
degree
we need student loan forgiveness beyond
the potential ten thousand dollars your
administration has
proposed we need at least a fifty
thousand dollar minimum
what will you do to make that happen i
will not make that happen
it depends on whether hey he's being
honest i mean listen i appreciate that
you rarely see uh that directive an
answer
i mean it's not it was never his
proposal
we can say that his proposal is bad
we can say it should be fifty thousand
he was never
gaslighting anybody um
we cannot with ten thousand give us a
break joe come on man i get it
he never said it was going to be 50 and
he's not pretending it's going to be 50
here i i think that's i i
appreciate this kind of honesty or not
you go to a private university or public
university
it depends on the idea that
i say to a community i'm going to
forgive the debt
the billions of dollars of debt for
people who have gone
to harvard and yale and penn and schools
my children i went to a great school i
went to a state school
right i mean like if trump were asked
this he would say
well we're looking at all of it and you
know the truth is college isn't for
everyone
and uh i mean we've got some real
problems in college you know when you
look at the professors and the teachers
and the indoctrination
and we've got to do patriotic education
here we've got to do patriotic education
but no no we're looking
at it very strongly and you're going to
hear something from us about it
over the next period of time that would
have been trump's answer
okay biden's saying i'm not doing 50k
okay hold on i'm told trump is speaking
now on fox news
is could that possibly be happening fox
news live
let's see allow ads on fox news
my god you got to be kidding me this is
completely toxic
look at this
okay oh my god can you oh no oh my god
all right i i don't know what's going on
we're not going to be able to find it
find a stream on youtube
let's see what is happening here as we
stand by for gen saki
um
i don't even know what uh oh fox news
live let's see
fox news live
oh boy trump is talking about
limbaugh okay
yeah i can't find it it doesn't matter
we'll we'll we're just gonna skip it
okay guys
it's just not worth it yeah exactly uh
okay let's listen to a little more of
joe biden on student loans
but is that going to be forgiven rather
than use that money
to provide for early education for young
children who are come from disadvantaged
circumstances but
here's what i think i think everyone and
i've been proposing this for
four years everyone should be able to go
to community college for free
for free all right so listen i
appreciate it joe biden's being honest i
wish he had a different plan but this is
his plan and he's being honest about it
um okay let's see trump called into fox
news what did he know was coming
so i did tell him beforehand because we
didn't
have the uh really the the
power of not doing it you know rush was
very sick at the time
he was at a hospital in boston and i
didn't want to do the surprise thing
uh i wish i wish i could have done that
but we really didn't have that
uh that that uh power of doing it
because he
had it was a very difficult thing for
him to come what is he talking about i
don't even know what he's talking about
he's so confusing
into washington from where he was
and he did it and there was questions as
to whether or not he was just a very
brave guy he's
amazing and he came in and it was as he
told me it was the greatest honor of his
life
and everybody in the room uh you know
you're talking about
the republicans and the democrats you
had half of that room went
crazy you remember the evening well i'm
sure it was very unique moment
yeah in our country's history in a sense
because of who russia is but
halfway just absolutely crazy the other
half sat
totally dead silent but a hundred
percent of that room
respected rush it was a unique guy and
he was a
i don't know that that's true he became
a friend of mine you know i didn't know
rush
at all i had essentially never met rush
and then when we came down the escalator
he
liked my rather controversial speech i
made that speech that was a little bit
on the controversial side and he loved
it
and he was without ever having met him
or talked to him or you know had lunch
with him and
asked him he was with me right from the
beginning
and he liked what i said and he agreed
with what i said
and he was just a great gentleman great
great man
all right so donald trump i guess in
only the way he can
sort of eulogizing rush limbaugh
uh and it seems that much like with all
of donald trump's relationships he liked
rush
because rush liked trump and
that is essentially how donald trump
operates
um not not a big surprise but donald
trump coming out of
hiding for um the purposes of
sort of eulogizing eulogizing uh rush
limbaugh there
okay i'm being told that naomi biden
has been doing some uh some interesting
tweeting
related to some kind of fox news anchor
someone give this man a hug a hug their
love is yeah that's the clip we looked
at earlier
okay all right not not the most
interesting thing but interesting
nonetheless
we are standing by for gen saki
originally scheduled for 12 30 p.m
eastern time
apparently rescheduled for 1pm eastern
time and we're now standing by and we'll
be hearing from her
uh about a number of different things
many many different things jensaki will
certainly be asked about and will
discuss with us
let's uh get back to some other super
chats uh trump on fox because of the
passing of rush yes
what's the best response in debate to
someone that compares trump insurrection
coupe to mike van der dean's propaganda
video
he presented at the impeachment trial
quotes from the dnc
uh i don't even know what
i'm not sure i totally understand
trump incited an insurrection and then
there was a riot
what was incited by people at the dnc i
mean
if you're referring to the fight
compilation where people say we're going
to fight for what you know for our
rights or whatever that's very very
different it seems like it would be
crazy to uh even equate the two
if you think it tastes good it's allowed
on pizza
absolutely i am a pizza libertarian
pineapple jalapeno and onion is my
favorite pizza
beautiful chicken and pineapple pizza
the only reason to have pineapple on
pizza is if the said pizza
also has ham or canadian bacon geez
hi david i enjoy your content and
commentary and
did biden address student loans yeah we
talked about that earlier very good
oh and joel checking in from switzerland
says huge fan from
switzerland by the way love switzerland
absolutely love switzerland
hope to get back there uh primarily i've
spent time in
uh zurich and lugano
zurich and lugano are the places i've uh
i've spent time
can you give the cliff notes on what
happened with the texas power and water
grid yeah
basically what happened is storm and
really cold
weather in texas caused power outages
now most of texas's power is from fossil
fuels
and most of the problems with their
power grid came from fossil fuels it was
instruments that froze at coal
natural gas and nuclear plants that's
the truth
however people like um who were they
people like greg abbott the governor
and tucker carlson and others said that
it's the green new deal respo this is a
preview of what
would happen under the green new deal
and the problem is
uh what is the prob the problem is wind
farms
and wind turbines that froze and of
course a few wind turbines did freeze
uh but really the problem was the fossil
fuel plants and of course
all of this stuff could have been dealt
with long ago if they had winterized
properly just a matter of winterization
all right let's see what else we've got
here
okay good we are very very close
to the start of this event
i'm glad you're with us implying we
can't forgive more in loans and fund k
through 12 at the same time isn't
honesty david honest about his policy
but dishonest about why
sure yeah but but he's not pretending
that he's going to do something he's not
going to do and i
i think that that's what he should be
doing
only listening peripherally are you
covering a football game hearing a lot
of talk about passing and rush
very clever did you see trump's letter
about mcconnell
keeping my fingers crossed for
republican infighting yeah we have a
on today's podcast which will be out in
a couple of hours
we have a segment about that chicken
mango
on pizza is delicious well it's
interesting one of my favorite
indian dishes is mango chicken that's as
close to a perfect dish as maybe you can
have
and tandoori love that tandoori chicken
thanks to john palumbo john palumbo
is new member number 45 today
also want to say thanks to taco light
kleinster pink and blonde shiloh pilot
and many others who signed up via twitch
to support putting us at exactly
50. and
um how close am i to 80 000 followers on
twitch
we're 250 away that's actually an
interesting question
can if you're in the chat and you're in
my stream but you don't follow me on
twitch
can you say something and tell me how
you found this stream like did twitch
recommend it to you i'm not i don't know
that much about the twitch algorithm
so i'm curious how people not following
me even come across
the stream everybody's saying that they
are followers
looked for me from youtube
interesting everyone okay here we go we
have another special guest with us here
today
uh joining us today is ann neuberger a
deputy national security advisor for
cyber
and emerging technology i told her
that's quite a title well she's here
cyberly for us the national security
agency's director of cyber security
where she led nsa's cyber security
mission prior to that role she led nsa's
election security effort and served as
assistant deputy director of nsa's
operations directorate overseeing
foreign intelligence and cyber security
operations
she also previously served as nsa's
first chief risk officer
as director of nsa's commercial solution
center as director of enduring security
framework
cyber security public-private
partnership as the navy's
deputy chief management officer and as a
white house fellow
she is going to provide all of you an
update on the administration's work
related to solar winds and she's willing
to take a couple of questions as usual i
will play the bad cop
come on over and when you're ready we'll
be hearing now from ann newberger
on solar winds good afternoon it's great
to be here with you today
so i'll give an update across our
solarwinds work
what happened how did it happen and what
are we doing about it right first
what happened hackers launched a broad
and indiscriminate effort
to compromise the network management
software used by both government
and the private sector the intelligence
community is looking at who is
responsible
until that study is complete i'll use
the language we previously used which
was to say
an advanced persistent threat actor
likely of russian origin
was responsible okay as of today
nine federal agencies and about a
hundred private sector companies were
compromised
as you know roughly eighteen thousand
entities downloaded the malicious update
so the scale of potential access far
exceeded the number of known compromises
many of the private sector compromises
are technology companies
including networks of companies whose
products could be used to launch
additional intrusions
so why does this matter why is this
significant the techniques that were
used
lead us to believe that any files or
emails on
a compromise network were likely to be
compromised
the scope and scale of our investigation
is underway and we look forward to
providing you future updates
in in the future so how did this happen
there's two parts to that them and us
the actor was a sophisticated advanced
persistent threat
advance because the level of knowledge
they showed about the technology
and the way they compromised it truly
was sophisticated
persistent they focused on the identity
part of the network which is the hardest
to clean up
and threat the scope and scale to
networks to information
makes this more than an isolated case of
espionage
and then us there's a lack of domestic
visibility
so as a country we choose to have both
privacy and security
so the intelligence community largely
has no visibility into private sector
networks
the hackers launched the hack from
inside the united states
which further made it difficult for the
us government to observe their activity
even within federal networks a culture
and
authorities inhibit visibility which is
something we need to address
i want to take a moment to thank the
public and private sector network
defenders who've been working
very hard to find and expel these
adversaries from both government and
private sector networks
so finally and most significantly what
are we going to do about it
right three things first finding and
expelling the adversary
second building back better to modernize
federal defenses
and reduce the risk of this happening
again and finally potential response
options
to the perpetrators so first finding and
expelling the adversary
we're coordinating the interagency
response from the national security
council
i was on the hill last week had hill
discussions this week and we'll be on
the hill
next week as well we're working closely
with daily conversations
with our private sector partners they
have visibility and technology
that is key to understanding the scope
and scale of compromise
there are legal barriers and
disincentives to the private sector
sharing information with the government
that is something we need to overcome
and then finally
this is challenging this is a
sophisticated actor who did their best
to hide their tracks
we believe it took them months to plan
and execute this compromise
it'll take us some time to uncover this
layer by layer
second building back better to modernize
federal defenses
we're absolutely committed to reducing
the risk this happens again
if you can't see a network you can't
defend a network and federal networks
cyber security
need investment and more of an
integrated approach to detect
and block such threats we're also
working
on close to about a dozen things likely
eight will pass
it'll be part of an upcoming executive
action to address
the gaps we've identified it in our
review of this incident
and finally in terms of response to the
perpetrator
discussions are underway i know some of
you will want to know what kind of
options are being contemplated
what i will share with you is how i
frame this in my own mind
this isn't the only case of malicious
cyber activity of likely russian origin
either for us or for our allies and
partners so as we contemplate future
response options we're considering
holistically
what those activities were i look
forward to coming back
and keeping you posted as we continue
identifying the scope and scale and
begin and continue our execution
and thank you so much for your
have any time thanks again for doing
this
just uh to 30 000 footage you have a
time frame in terms of how long this
investigation will take and then
obviously you're not going to lay out
specific details of what you will do in
response but do you have a timeline on
the response as well as a tag to
whenever the investigation ends
or how are you guys thinking through
that so most importantly as we're
looking at what caused the solar winds
we're also executing the three things i
talked about we're working to expel the
adversary
we're working to build those networks
and improve the cyber security of
federal networks
and we're also carefully thinking
through how we respond so the
investigation as i noted because of the
sophistication
it's taking us layer by layer but we're
working at the same pace to ensure we
lock down networks and really think
through how to ensure this doesn't
happen again in the future
do you have a timeline i understand it's
complicated but how long it would take
to go layer by layer and really
understand the graphics of the scope
i think we're estimating several months
but as i said
literally you know day by day hour by
hour
we're making progress in understanding
it as you look at the scope and the
scale of this
do you have a price tag or a sense of a
price tag that could begin to account
the total cost of damage to the us
government from this compromise
it's a really interesting question
there's two parts right one is it's
really
highlighted the investments we need to
make in cyber security to have the
visibility to block these attacks in the
future
and then the second is the scale of the
information that was potentially
compromised
and the impact of how that information
could be used in the hands of a
malicious actor
so it's there's certainly uh a cost with
regard to dollars it's also a cost with
regard to national security
and we're bounding and understanding
both and there's been some discussion
that entire networks could have to be
scrapped and rebuilt essentially from
the ground up
i know you know you don't get the
specifics of a timeline but are we
talking about
years potentially to try and secure some
of these networks going forward
we certainly don't have years it's wise
when planning in cyber security to
consider the worst case particularly
when you're dealing with such a
sophisticated attacker
in that way so we know we don't have
years and the
remediation the fix and cleanup work is
underway already
and we'll be doing it in a careful way
to ensure that we lock down layer by
layer but we know it's going to be a lot
shorter than that
and what have we specifically learned
about this attack in terms of kind of
the data that was stolen
and you know agencies that were impacted
we know the number
but what kind of communications were
really impacted by this hack
good question one of the things we've
done from the white house is do a
coordinated set of questions to assess
that
and pull that piece together it varies
agency by agency
and certainly there is national security
impact and that is what we're looking to
consider
both how we manage the risk of that and
how we address it for the future
and do we have any understanding of kind
of the motive that that drove this
uh this attack i mean based on the
assessment that you've had
what what were the hackers really trying
to go after i mean any particular agency
out of the nine that you that you found
that they were going after certainly as
we look at the agencies there are a
number of those of high foreign
intelligence interest
to a foreign government so we know that
was certainly one goal
but as i noted earlier when there is a
compromise of this scope and scale
both across government and across the
u.s technology sector to lead to
follow-on intrusions
it is more than a single incident of
espionage
it's fundamentally of concern for the
ability for this to become disruptive
since it's involved both the government
agencies in the private sector as well
how much were you able to share with the
private sector as far as
you know what may have been compromised
on their end and what they can do maybe
to prevent this from happening again
in the u.s government in the united
states the way we're structured
public-private partnership
has to be a core part of national cyber
defense so there's active sharing going
on
in both directions government sharing
its insights with private sector
entities both who have been compromised
and those who have broader visibility
and private sector entities sharing
their insights to ensure we can together
scope and scale what occurred one more
question go ahead
um do you believe you'll find additional
u.s agencies and private companies that
have been hacked or is it gonna
is this the the final number um and have
you rule out data deletion or
manipulation
so due to the sophistication of the
techniques that were used
we believe we're in the beginning stages
of understanding the scope and scale and
we may find
additional compromises particularly
given the technology companies that were
compromised
and no we have not ruled out potential
additional activity but we're very
focused on
carefully taking this step by step to
understand the broad implications
thank you anne so much and we of course
would love to have you back
any time thank you all thank you so
that's an update on that big hack that
took place now we'll hear from jenn
socks
additional updates for all of you uh
today president biden will meet with
labor leaders
to thank them for their role
representing workers and supporting a
strong
american middle class and to discuss the
importance of passing the american
rescue plan
which will not only help contain the
pandemic and deliver immediate economic
relief but will also
create jobs including good union jobs
today our coveted response team also
announced critical steps to expand
testing in the united states a critical
piece of turning the tight
the tide of the pandemic and protecting
our public health
today they have announced that the
federal government will invest
1.6 billion dollars already allocated
funds
but in three areas and this includes 650
million to support
testing in schools and underserved
communities
hhs will use these funds to create
regional coordinating centers that will
partner with labs to leverage their
underutilized testing capacity
these coordinating centers will help
match lab capacity with demand from
schools congregate settings
like homeless shelter shelters or other
underserved populations
almost 200 million dollars will go to
increase genomic sequencing
the surge in funding will result in a
three-fold increase in the cdc's genomic
sequencing capacity
to get us to 25 000 samples a week this
will help us identify variants
sooner which is obviously important and
pivotal at this point in time
and 815 million dollars will go to
manufacture critical testing supplies on
things like
filter pipette tips nitrocellulose used
in antigen tests
and specialized injection molded
plastics needed to house
testing regions these are critical steps
to address vital issues this funding in
these efforts are far from what is
necessary it simply provides a bridge
to the funding that is in in the
american rescue plan
which will help us get more shots into
the arms of americans
i also have an update on the winter
storms in texas which i know is of great
interest to many of you
our team and fema continue to monitor
the situation in texas
as well as other states in the storm's
path that might be impacted
we remain in close contact with states
across the affected area to ensure
any federal support requirements are met
fema has supplied generators to texas
and is preparing to move
diesel into the state to ensure the
continued availability of backup power
which of course is a major issue on the
ground to key critical infrastructure
including communications hospitals and
water
fema is also supplying texas with water
and blankets at their requests
we're preparing to quickly process
requests from other states for emergency
assistance that's how the process
typically works
and we urge people in the affected
states to of course listen to their
emergency management officials
final updates ahead of the meeting this
afternoon the president is taking
several steps to expand high quality
registered apprenticeships to reward
work rebuild the middle class
and connect a diverse workforce to
family supporting living wage jobs
specifically today he is
endorsing congressman scott's national
apprenticeship act
which the house estimates will create
nearly one million new apprenticeship
opportunities
and help ensure women and workers of
color benefit
he's reinstating the long-standing
national advisory committee on
apprenticeships
which will help will bring the voice of
unions employers community colleges and
other institutions to expanding
and improving the registered
apprenticeship programs and that he is
signing an executive order that reverses
trump's executive order former president
trump's executive order
which spurred the creation of industry
recognized apprenticeship programs
these programs lack quality standards
and threaten to undermine the registered
apprenticeship programs
that have been the pathway to middle
class for decades i said that was the
last step one more thing
also today the president nominated
jennifer arruzo as general counsel of
the national labor relations board
and many of you have been following the
change over of leadership there
having spent more than 20 years working
for the nlrb
abruzzo will bring with her deep
experience and knowledge of the nlrb's
role and will be an important partner in
building a strong and more resilient and
more inclusive
economy that delivers every american a
fair return for their work
with that a couple things at the top go
ahead thanks i had a
couple of questions uh sort of
follow-ups from yesterday and this
morning
on two different issues these are circle
backs getting the five days
a week school the vice president this
morning i believe said it's a priority
to get vaccinations
for teachers um can you get to five days
a week
without vaccinations does the president
believe
that teachers need to be vaccinated uh
before they
go back to school uh no neither the
president nor the vice president
believe that that it should be it is a
requirement
this the cdc guidelines included
a range of mitigation steps including
vaccinations as recommendations but the
mitigation steps also included
steps like social distancing the need
for
uh smaller class sizes the need for
sanitation
so these are this was one of several
steps recommended in the cdc guidelines
now at the same time the president and
the vice president both believe that
t-shirts should be prioritized and as
you all know
that's up to states to determine there
are federal recommendations about half
of the country half
about half of the states in the country
have prioritized teachers
and they both feel that's important
including child health care workers
um and they both feel that that's
something that is impacting
working women and moms who are trying to
go back to work and trying to make sure
that their kids have the attention and
child care they need so
it's not a requirement to reopen schools
but they believe that teachers should be
prioritized
and on the impact particularly women you
just mentioned
also the idea of getting to that 7
million number that the president talked
about
yesterday that if you pass the plan you
can get
all the estimates that say you can get
seven million jobs back this year
yeah how can you do that without getting
back to five days of school how do women
go back to work
without having their kids full time good
question
well i will say one of the reasons that
the president has
put 130 billion dollars of funding in
his american rescue plan is because
he knows that schools across the country
need funding to
satisfy some of the mitigation steps
that are recommended in the cdc
guidelines
i talked with him about this this
morning and his concern as you have
raised that
this is deeply impacting women we're
seeing that statistically with every
week and every month of
jobs numbers we've seen it anecdotally
and his concern is about the impact of
course on
working women today but also on how it
will uh it will bring us back
uh in the years ahead because if there
are fewer women who are in the workplace
there are fewer women climbing the
corporate ladder
there are fewer women who are getting
law degrees
getting doctorates and that has a
long-term impact so
you're right that or i should say what
i'm taking from your question
is you know can we can we get this done
if we don't have funding if we don't
have the different components
when he announced his goal of opening
the majority of schools
he made clear we need to have funding
because most many schools will tell you
across the country
they were waiting for the cdc guidelines
they want to know how to do it safely
but
they don't have they need the funding to
hire more teachers they need more bus
drivers they need
uh the ability to implement the
mitigation steps that are going to work
for their school districts
it's one last thing from last night
president biden said no one should go to
jail for a drug offense
no he said for having drugs or using
drugs uh well anyone who
uh had the pleasure of journeying around
the country with him before kovid and
and then i think he's not being accurate
about what biden said it was happening
uh remotely he talked again and again on
the
campaign trail about eliminating
mandatory minimums
and making sure that people suffering
from addiction aren't incarcerated for
drug
use alone but instead are sent to
treatment that's reflected
plan he put forward on the campaign and
that's his goal as president
and of course we're four weeks in so
there's a lot more policy work to be
done
uh but that is a that is a commitment
and a
policy proposal or policy uh commitment
he talked about on the campaign trail
um uh go ahead hi thank you um just a
couple of follow-ups again from last
night sure
the president mentioned um that you know
china will face repercussions
uh for human rights abuses against
uyghurs and in hong kong
and taiwan etc um what did he
specifically mean by repercussions i
mean is
is the white house considering sanctions
or uh
even under trump there was a lot of
chinese companies that were
added to a economic blacklist is that
likely to continue as you
evaluate your options how are you
thinking in terms of
repercussions well what the president
the full context of his comments was
also about how during his conversation
with president xi
he uh talked about the values of the
united states and that
the fact is is that even when you are
communicating with another world leader
and you're having a tough conversation
we can't our values and our um and our
priorities uh whether it's
human rights as it relates to the
uyghurs uh and what they have suffered
through
or the freedom of press or media they
can't take a back seat and so
the context of his comments were that
those are issues he's going to continue
to raise
as it relates to our policy toward china
we are not in a rush we are focused on
communicating and working with our
partners and allies around the world
the president has had a number of
conversations as you know with europeans
uh he will continue uh conversations
with world leaders
in the weeks ahead but uh uh beyond that
uh there's an ongoing policy process and
i don't have anything uh to preview for
you today so so
you know just in terms of the existing
restrictions um that were put under the
previous administration
are they likely to continue as you sort
of you know take your time and sort of
have a measured response to this well i
wouldn't i didn't call it a measured
response uh what i conveyed was
that our process is to ensure that we
are
strengthening uh our economy at home we
can we want to come to our
approach to china to that relationship
from a position of strength
uh that is something the president is
national security team are doing
uh he is also going to communicate we
see our relationship with
china as one focused around competition
uh he's also going to focus on
working with our partners and allies
around the world in europe and in asia i
don't have anything to preview for you
in terms of additional policy steps
other than to convey for you broadly
that's our approach and when he was
answering the question at the town hall
he was reiterating his view
that as president and his commitment i
should say that he is not going to
miss an opportunity to restate his
values and our values as a country
uh go ahead oh i could come back to you
but go ahead on the issue
of teachers you're making it clear that
a vaccination isn't a must as the cdc
recommends but that you hope that states
prioritize this
is this administration sharing that
message with teachers is the president
been reiterating that with governors
urging them
to put teachers at the front of the line
the president uh
absolutely it's something he said at a
nationally televised town hall meeting
last night and something that
he will continue to communicate at every
opportunity and
uh you know i think what i was conveying
just for full clarity
is that it's a recommendation it's a
number one of many mitigation steps
but the cdc guidelines are guidelines
they're not requirements
uh but at the same time the president
the vice president believe that the
teachers should be prioritized in many
states they already are
but you do agree with the guidelines you
do agree with the cdc recommendation
that the
vaccinations are not a must for teachers
that it is one of
correct that is one of mitigation and a
number of mitigation steps that should
be taken
by schools to keep things safe now it's
important to also reiterate um and when
i talked to the president this morning
he conveyed this again
that we need money these school
districts need money
to deliver on these guidelines and when
his secretary of education
is confirmed hopefully next week i'll
knock on some wood
then he will be leading this effort this
will be his number one priority is
working with these school districts
to safely reopen as quickly as possible
the timeline for widespread vaccine
availability keeps getting pushed back
originally it seemed we were eyeing
sometime in the spring now the president
last night said the end of july
so when do we expect that there will be
enough doses for everyone who wants a
vaccine to be able to get one
well the president actually now i know
we've been putting out a lot of covet
news i realized that almost every day
the president actually announced last
week or we announced last week that he
would be purchasing
uh that the federal government would be
purchasing enough doses
to vaccinate 300 million americans so he
reiterated that
last night we will get the last shipment
of those doses the end of july
by the end of may we will have about 400
million doses
so at that point once we have 400
million doses
there will certainly be a larger swath
of people who will be eligible who will
be able to get access to vaccine but in
terms of
when every american who wants a vaccine
who can get a vaccine uh we will have
enough doses by the end of july and
those have already been ordered from
yeah it's really a matter of how quickly
they'll be able to inject them and if
you're gonna
get up to three and a half million a day
then do the math it'll happen pretty
quickly
so it seems to be shifting dr fauci had
said a sense of normalcy maybe in the
fall
that's when you might be able to go to
theaters go to sporting events still
with mass of course
now it seems that's being slid to early
next year the president said maybe
around christmas
what's going on here when do we think we
will get back to some
taste of normalcy well this is the
question as i'm sure is the case for all
of you that every neighbor
every friend every family member asks
at least me in the street when i'm
walking my dog in the morning um
we want to be straight with the american
public though it is we are not in a
place where we can predict
exactly when everybody will feel normal
again and it has there are a number of
reasons
one is even though we will have enough
doses for every person in this country
as you all know because we've talked
about it in here vaccine hesitancy
remains a challenge
uh we need to ensure that you're not
going to get anything new from her right
now i mean it's how many people want the
vaccine how many can we do
per day uh how quickly do cases continue
to decline how quickly can we
fight basically the variance and
vaccinate more quickly than the variants
are spreading we just we're just not
sure you know i'm sure
there will be states that will be very
open by may 1st i mean the truth is a
lot of them are going to be open earlier
than that probably too soon
there are other places that are going to
keep guidelines in place for probably
most of this year it's just not clear
are the goals as they're laid out right
now for reopening
entirely contingent on having the 130
billion dollars or those goals
to reopen a majority of schools by the
end of 100 days
based on not having that money and that
money will only serve to turbo charge
things
well when the president announced his
goal of reopening the majority of
schools in 100 days he conveyed
that money was a pivotal part of that
and it is
and it is not it is up to of course
local school districts to determine
which mitigation steps they will take
it is up to them to uh to determine how
they will use accessible funds
but that funding is needed by school
districts across the country and
i think will be you know essential to
our success
i'm asking is the scale of what the cdc
is recommending in terms of the changes
some schools would have to make whether
it's through their hvac systems or their
spacing or as you know
hiring bus drivers teachers that would
take time it takes time to get money out
the door
how does that impact the first hundred
days
it it it impacts it because it means
there's an urgency to getting this money
through and to ensuring that that
schools have the ability to plan ahead
some of these schools and obviously i'm
not speaking to any particular district
but broadly speaking
you know they have funding that they can
front load right but they need to know
their security of funding that is ahead
and so this funding is essential to
being able to provide the necessary
resources to
many schools across the country that
want to implement
these mitigation measures take the steps
work with their local school districts
and school boards to do it but don't
have the resources to
effectively do it and again as soon as
our education secretary is sworn in uh
this is going to be his number one
priority okay just go ahead
really quick sure the president
mentioned it didn't seem like he was
endorsing it just that he mentioned that
the idea of summer school uh is that
something he would want every kid on
summer school
the um but is that something he would
like to see i know it's in the
discussion and i know it's about the
school districts and
is that something he'd like to do if
schools are able to reopen to have full
semesters for summer school
well it is something that is an option
and uh you know our department of
education is also undergoing uh
a study to determine the impact of covid
on kids and schools and what is the
impact of
uh doing remote learning what's the
impact yeah it would be good to mention
ultimately that's up to the states the
federal government can't decide that
you know they'll be able to work with
school districts on what's going to work
best to address the challenges and needs
that they're finding through that study
but this funding that is in the american
rescue plan can be used for
a range of purposes and we've talked
about a lot of them bus drivers
uh hiring of temporary teachers uh you
know
ppe or other equipment but also can be
used for tutoring or summer school in
cases where that would be an appropriate
step and
it's really going to be up to the school
districts to determine that go ahead
you've said that you've said that the
president's preference is that
states prioritize teachers this is a
vaccine that's being provided
for free to the states by the federal
government
can't you mandate that states prioritize
teachers
we can provide federal guidelines which
is exactly what we've done
but we work in close partnership and
coordination with states to
make recommendations on the
prioritization and they implement
of course the the power of the
presidency and the power of the vice
presidency is certainly conveying what
their
preference this is a good question the
question is you've
you've chosen not to try to tell states
exactly what they have to do but
couldn't you say we will only up your
supply if you include teachers
i think they could do that legally eight
through eight schools open five days a
week five day 100
what about high schools what's the goal
for them i'm not going to set new goals
here other than to say that the
president wants
students to be in school learning with
their teachers
five days a week and he wants that to
happen as quickly as possible
and do it safely and he's obviously said
he wants that to happen
in the first hundred days it is harder
and we saw this in the cdc guidelines
but also from many of our health experts
because of social distancing
it is more challenging with older
students than it is with younger
students and that of course it has to be
a factor and
something that i'm sure school districts
will consider but they're also suffering
more aren't they well again there's a
study that our department of education
is undergoing uh to provide to acquire
data to uh
make a determination about
recommendations on how to address the
impacts
um we'll let them speak to that but i
think we can all see anecdotally of
course what the impact is on older
students
we want students to be back in the
classroom but we want to do it safely uh
and and the president's committed to
doing that and then finally you said
previously that the goal was to have the
majority of k-8 schools open
at least one day a week in the first 100
days last night
president biden called that a mistake in
communication he wants them open five
days a week
so can you clarify what is the
administration's goal for reopening k-8
schools in the first 100 years
i'm not going to take it personally that
you don't hang on every word that i say
in here
i did say last thursday that the
president will not rest until every
school is open
five days a week that is our goal that
is what we want to achieve but we are
going to we look forward to seeing and
hearing the cdc guidelines to gain a
better understanding of what steps
that will entail or should entail i also
said i can assure
any parent listening that is objective
his commitment is to ensure schools are
open five days a week
so i think we've been consistent for the
last several days and certainly when i
initially said one day a week it was our
it was our floor it was not our ceiling
but uh without a doubt the president
wants schools to open five days a week
wants students to be in the classroom
wants to do that safely we now have some
guidelines from the cdc with several
mitigation steps
uh we'll have to work we need funding to
do that that is a pivotal piece of it
many school districts need funding they
don't have it
uh and also we need our secretary of
education in place to
work to implement thank you sure go
ahead another follow-up on last night
the president said pretty clearly that
he doesn't think
he has the authority to cancel fifty
thousand dollars in
student loan debt today senator schumer
and warren
said in a statement that they were told
the administration is still working
on figuring out if it has the authority
so if your lawyers would determine that
canceling this is legal
would the president go ahead with this
and if not why not
well first on last night uh last night's
town hall for those of you didn't see
the whole thing uh
he was reiterating his previously stated
position which is he doesn't favor fifty
thousand dollars in student loan relief
without
limitation and he used some examples of
the types of schools or when it should
be
we looked at that refunded he said
previously that relief above ten
thousand dollars should be targeted
based on the borrower's income based on
the kind of debt in question
public schools versus private schools
graduate schools versus undergraduate
obviously there's a lot of
considerations
at play what the president has told
senator schumer and warren
is that once his team is in place at the
justice department and they are not
of course they're they're not confirmed
at this point he will ask them to
conduct a legal legal review of his
authority
uh to act by executive action in
conjunction with a policy review from
his domestic policy council
on his executive on how executive action
debt relief
if any should be targeted so obviously
that's a review that would need to take
place there's a legal consideration
there as i think everybody
agrees there's a policy consideration
and once that's concluded he'll decide
the path forward
so he hasn't yet ruled it out if all of
these ifs and bots are still
in place and obviously you need your
team in place and the review to take
place
that's right there needs to be a team at
the justice department to make a
recommendation on his legal authority
and obviously the domestic policy team
is in place but they would be a part of
that conversation
certainly as well and in the meantime if
congress moves forward and
sends him a package that uh you know
provides ten thousand dollars of student
debt relief
he'd be eager to sign that uh so there
are several lovers here and he's
he's um looking forward to that process
moving forward
um go ahead oh you go ahead go ahead
yeah
sorry i know it's like my point is kind
of all over the place um the president
during
the campaign supported the
study corporations the committee to
study reparations there was a house
judiciary committee hearing
today um does the president support the
legislation he stopped short of saying
that during the campaign
would he sign that if it came to his
desk well he supported a study of
reparations which i believe is what's
being discussed
and studying the continuing impacts of
slavery which is being discussed in this
hearing on h.r 40 i believe it is and he
continues to
demonstrate his commitment to take
comprehensive action to address the
systemic racism
that persists today obviously that is uh
having that study is a part of that but
he has
signed an executive order on his first
day uh which would begin
to deliver on his commitment to having
an
across government approach to addressing
uh racial inequality and
and making sure equity is a part of his
entire policy agenda
but he certainly would support a study
of reparations and we understand
understands that this is the absence of
a yes that biden supports reparations
which is not news we knew that
in the meantime would he support the
bill because you're talking about the
study but if the bill came together
well it's working its way through
congress he'd certainly support a study
but
we'll see what happens through the
legislative process there you go
question on that
um the president has done quite a few
executive actions
why not on this issue create a
commission and by executive order
he actually signed a number of actions
on racial equity
in on his first day or his first couple
days in office
because he felt it was essential to
send the message to the american people
and the world that
uh having an across government approach
ensuring that equities
is a central part of his policy agenda
was you know not just a a single a
singular issue but something that would
be a part of every policy issue
he approaches whether it's healthcare
whether it's economic inequality
a range of issues that's his approach
and how he's trying to
um you know change address the root
causes of racism in our country today
but he doesn't support a reparations
executive order he won't sign them
again he well it would be up to him it's
a you know he has executive order
authority he would
certainly support uh a study um and
we'll see where congress moves
on that issue go ahead um just again uh
you know you're getting a lot of
follow-ups from last night and one more
um the president's book i welcome echo
the president spoke about uh minimum
wage
last night and reiterated his support
for uh 15
an hour um and at the same time
uh you know he also tried to explain
sort of a a gradual rollout and he spoke
about 12
13. we appreciate the clarification your
office put out this morning about uh
about
what that would look like i'm just
trying to get a better understanding of
whether the white house will still
insist that 15
go into the into the bill uh the covet
uh relief bill
now and and if it if that is not
happening what is the
path forward is it the house legislation
uh talking about
uh you know 15 by october 2025 is that
what the white house will support if
this doesn't happen
what is it looking like well uh we're in
the middle of the legislative process
for the american rescue plan
and uh we fully recognize as does the
president having served in the senate
for 36 years that
his bill that he proposed that included
a 15 minimum wage increase included many
other key components
may not look exactly the same on the
other end when it comes out of the
sausage making machine
but he put it in there the uh raise of
the minimum wage because he
it feels it's important it's a priority
and that uh
men and women who are working hard who
are
living on you know making honest living
shouldn't be living at the public i
think it's important to remember that
there's still democrats in the senate
who don't support a 15 minimum wage like
joe manchin for example so when you
already talk about 17 18 21 or whatever
i mean okay great let's have let's have
a conversation about whatever
not even every democrat's on board with
15 yet this package will become
a reality we'll see it's up to members
of congress to determine uh what the
final package looks like it's a priority
to the president that's why he put it in
the package
but he also and i appreciate you
referencing uh uh you know the
the sorry the the ex the
right exactly i just like stumbled over
100 words i appreciate you referencing
that
uh when he was asked this question last
night it was by a small business owner
who was concerned
uh that immediately he would or this is
what the president's takeaway was
that immediately he would be in a place
where he had to pay his workers
15 an hour next month or soon
uh and the president was explaining to
him that this would be
a you know progressive increase right
and that's something that senator
sanders
supports as well so he was explaining it
would go to 12 then it would go to 13 it
would be over a series of time over a
couple of years
so that was how he was explaining it but
again the process is ongoing
we look forward to it moving forward
rapidly and we'll see what comes out on
the other side so he definitely supports
even a gradual rollout
as as an option on the table oh
absolutely he supports a gradual
increase that it wouldn't be an
immediate and as the senator sanders and
as do many advocates for increasing the
minimum wage absolutely go ahead i
wanted to ask one
point of clarification on the summer
school uh question
um are you saying that there would be an
additional funding stream for schools
that wanted to go in that direction or
it would be part of the larger cobia
package
it's part of the larger it's an option
in the school funding that's in the
covet package
beyond that is the department of
education going to make an ultimate
recommendation on how districts should
handle the question of
holding in-person summer education for
students who have been out of the
classroom for so long
i'm sure that's something they'll look
at and i think what they're eager to
have access to
is this data on what the impact has been
of
students being out of school students
learning remotely hybrid learning
we don't know there's not really a big
precedent for this and they want to be
able to look at that data
and of course secretary cardona as a
former educator himself i guess once an
educator always an educator
uh will be leading that effort and
working with school districts let me ask
one more
on a different topic just because it's
an issue that's come up in congress it's
being
talked about in ndc is does the
president given his relationship with
the senate
have a view on permanent fencing around
the u.s capitol
it's likely something that if it were to
happen would be an appropriation that
the president would have to sign
it it's really up to congress to
determine uh
what measures need to be taken and i'm
sure they're working with their own
uh the capitol police and others to make
that determination but we don't have any
further comment from here or evaluation
um go ahead thanks jen um a top cdc
official and
uh transportation secretary brutal judge
paul said publicly in recent weeks that
coveted testing for domestic flights
was under consideration and i know you
said last week that those reports were
inaccurate
um and the cdc cdc issued a statement
saying
it's not recommending it but i guess why
is domestic testing no longer on the
table at a time when
countries like canada are significantly
increasing covered travel restrictions
and did the white house have a
conversation with the cdc
about the proposal given the pressure
coming from the airline industry
no there's a policy process for every
consideration right and obviously we
have said we will
lead with the guidance of health and
science experts and as you noted the cdc
put out a statement
on this last week there are steps that
we have put in place
as you may be familiar with including
mandatory masking on flights which
our health experts feel is an effective
uh step that that should be taken on
airlines
uh and also we've limited uh restricted
travel from uh
in international travel uh but that's
not a step that uh
was determined uh was essential to be
made um so we
will follow the guidelines uh go ahead
thanks
um i want to get back to the texas
crisis so
about a decade ago federal regulators
suggested they urge texas
to weatherize i covered this today
that largely did not happen or it
certainly didn't happen enough
uh and of course it was only a
suggestion because texas is not part of
the national grid
you may have seen that rick perry the
former energy secretary and governor of
texas
has has said today that uh texans would
rather
endure days of blackouts than submit to
federal regulations
i don't know about that the president
willing to leave 30 million texans off
of the national grid
there's a lot packed into that question
not up to the president i will do my
best to
answer it um let me first say that
building resilient and sustainable
infrastructure that can withstand
extreme weather and a changing climate
will play an integral role in creating
millions of good paying union jobs
creating a clean energy economy and
meeting
the president's goal of reaching a net
zero emissions feature by 2050 and also
will be beneficial in future storms
i will say that there has been some uh
inaccurate accusations out there i'm not
sure if former
secretary perry made these but uh
that it was the fi that that suggested
um
that uh renewables caused failures um
in texas's power grid and actually
numerous reports have actually shown the
contrary
that it was failures in coal and natural
gas that contributed to the state's
power shortages
and officials at the electric
reliability council of texas
which operates the state's power grid
have gone so far as to say that failures
in wind and solar were the least
significant factors
in the blackouts i know that wasn't
exactly your question but i just wanted
to the most relevant
answer and a lot of confusion about it
beyond that about the power grid i would
certainly
send you to the department of energy for
any further uh comment
on that particular line of questioning
um also on the crisis a lot of texans
are concerned
that their homeowners insurance is not
going to cover
for instance pipes that burst
i some policies might cover that some
might not will fema
make people hold for that kind of damage
i would i would certainly send you to
fema they obviously as i noted
generators water essential steps um but
in any crisis in the recovery of it
there are typically many agencies
involved
fema's a coordinating body as you all
know but just for others
uh but i would send you to them for any
uh other update on that all right a
quick
question from this morning the president
received ashes for ash wednesday
um what if anything is he giving up for
lent
oh what a good question i should have
asked him that question today um
not super relevant we'll have to follow
up with you on that particular question
i don't know sometimes people don't give
something up sometimes they do something
good
he's giving up brisket but i will see if
i can get more information i'm sorry i
have a question from outside the room
sure quick question
there's a move apparently to rename the
las vegas airport
for harry reid any idea if the president
would suggest
mccarran airport i have not spoken with
him about that
i know obviously he has a great deal of
respect for senator reid they worked
together for many years he was
an incredibly important partner during
the obama biden administration to the
then vice president um but in terms of
the renaming of airports i believe
that's congress to determine that but i
will
i will see if the president has any
further comment on it he's a big harry
reid fan
oh my god thanks jen i have a couple
different questions first of all is the
president going to release a statement
or say something about rush limbaugh
i know obviously the news just came out
in about the last hour before i had come
out
i can say i'm not sure if we'll release
a statement from the president he has
spoken to
in the past to uh to rush limbaugh's
sickness and illness at the time and
certainly
um you know he his condolences go out to
the family and the friends
of rush limbaugh who have of course have
lost
him today but i don't know that i
anticipate a statement from the
president but i can certainly
pass on his uh condolences and
expression of support for the family
and on a different topic is the
administration going to get involved in
the case of
princess latifah the daughter of the
dubai ruler who has released videos
claiming to be held hostage
that's princess not queen latifah on
that particular question as well
go ahead in the back thanks jen um i
want to ask you about the the meeting
that's going to take place
in a little bit with the labor leaders
richard trumka head of the afl-cio has
said in the past that he believes the
president learned a lesson with his
keystone decision that if you're going
to make a
decision in which jobs are lost you
should have a specific simultaneous
announcement
in which there are jobs added trump has
said quote
i wish he hadn't speaking of the
president done that on the first day
because the labors
laborers international was right the
labor international has said that a
thousand jobs were lost
i'm wondering is the president going to
bring this issue up when he meets
with the labor leaders did the president
learn any lesson
as richard trumka suggested and is he
open to potentially
uh looking at this decision once again
from from another angle
well this is not the first time this has
happened in here where there's been
about
half of richard trumka's statement or
comment in that particular interview
shared and not the full context
and the other context i unfortunately
don't have it in front of me
is about his belief that the president
is committed to
creating good paying union jobs
and that is certainly what will be
central to the discussion the president
has with
union leaders today including his desire
to
create good clean energy union
good paying union jobs and that he
believes that those two
can simultaneously happen he when he put
out his clean energy plan
last year he had union leaders and
environmentalists at the same table
agreeing to the path forward and he has
a
extensive record on this particular
issue i will say since you gave me the
opportunity
a clean uh prior to covid 19 the bureau
of labor and statistics reported that
two of the fastest growing
jobs were in the wind turbine and solar
industries and not just the start
the national academies of sciences
reported last week that a transition to
a net zero emissions economy could grow
millions of jobs over the next
decade and our plan the president's plan
which he'll talk about today will make
historic investments in infrastructure
in the auto industry and transit in the
power sector
creating millions of good union jobs and
in the process
also addressing the climate crisis head
on i'm sure he'll talk about that with
the union leaders today can i ask you
about other future plans as well
sure you said yesterday uh quote we
haven't yet determined what the next
priority forward would be but he meaning
the president is engaging with his
policy team
earlier this month when the president
met in the oval with house democrats
he said quote i can hardly wait to sit
down with peter defazio to work on
infrastructure
this is the next big piece so i'm
wondering he is excited about
infrastructure and i'm sure he will be
talking about it today it'll be
infrastructure week soon peace or is the
administration trying to figure out what
the next big piece will be
well first i will say uh our focus right
now and the president's focus
is on the american rescue plan and
moving that doing everything he can
to move that through congress to
communicate with the american public one
of the things i think that
she might want to adopt is to get away
from saying what i would say about that
is
it's sort of like when in writing people
are sometimes
they they say i think you're writing it
we know it's what you think
i i think that jen does a very good job
but i think she would be well advised to
get away from what i would say about
that almost like everything is
i've calculated the answer to your
question and what i'm going to spit out
is just give us the answer and if what
you're saying is the position of the
administration say
the position of the administration is i
think that that would be easy for her to
adopt
fashion four he does believe it creates
good paying union jobs he thinks they
can be done
as clean energy jobs but we're going to
focus our efforts
uh at this point in time on the american
rescue plan
one more um the vice president said i'm
speaking of
vaccines and distribution cohabit et
cetera she said quote
in many ways we are starting from
scratch on something that's been raging
for almost a year however
dr fauci has recently said quote we're
not starting from scratch because there
is activity going on
in the distribution and even today uh
your administration said that there was
i believe the number was 892
000 doses that were administered in the
final week before the president took
over
um so is that the best message to say
that
this administration started from scratch
when there were indeed
doses going out the door and folks like
dr fauci say that's
that's not the case well i don't think
most governors or most of the american
people
would tell you that they think it was
handled effectively and efficiently by
the prior administration
uh given we are we are when when the
president came in and the vice president
came in
there were not enough vaccines there
were not enough vaccinators there were
not enough vaccine vaccination locations
they've taken significant steps to
address all of those issues
yes in the week prior to the president
taking office
there were about 800 to 900 000 as you
said
doses doing uh uh being given a day the
on
the average was about 400 to 500 000
prior to that
last week the average was 1.7 million a
day
so there are significant steps that have
been taken what they were conveying
was that uh we did not have a
comprehensive plan there were not enough
vaccines there was not enough
coordination
with governors and local officials and
there were not enough places where
people could get the vaccine
and now we're working to address that
and it was important for the vice
president to convey that because the
american people need to know what we're
digging out of
uh and that was why she said it go ahead
oh let me go to the back because he
hasn't had a question
to you um question on tokyo games
so presidents say any decision must be
based on science
but i'd like to know how soon he expects
to see a final decision
if there were any tokyo begins on the
schedules
as of now is he confident that we have
saved olympic games in tokyo
i just don't have an update i understand
the question lots of focus and interest
on the olympics but i don't have any
update from here
he will participate in the g7 uh meeting
this coming friday
and this time he will focus on pandemic
economic and china
but it should expect to be more
discussions such as
tokyo some olympic games people just
love the olympics
that are raised by the members of the g7
it's important opportunity to have a
conversation and obviously he'll be
delivering remarks
i think we'll be previewing his remarks
which will give him a little bit more
time to work on since he was traveling
yesterday
uh later probably tomorrow night in
advance of friday and
there'll be more of an overview of what
we you should expect him to talk about
go ahead yes i would just have a point
of clarification on student loans um
as i understood it last night at the
town hall president biden said he was
prepared to write off ten thousand
dollars in loans
but not fifty thousand dollars because
he doesn't think he has the authority
and and you said that that legal review
still has to take place but is the door
for the president himself is the door to
50 000
essentially closed at this point the the
president has previously stated that he
does not favor fifty thousand dollars in
student loan relief without limitation
and some of what he talked about last
night much more extensively than what
i'm about to say
but is that uh you know there are a lot
of factors public schools versus private
schools graduate schools versus
undergraduate schools
uh and he also believes that relief
above he continues to believe that
relief above ten thousand dollars should
be targeted
and ten thousand dollars he's conveyed
because there's been proposals in
congress as you probably know
that he'd be eager to sign that bill
that congress can pass
but yes there is a legal review there's
going to be a review by our domestic
policy team
to consider all of these options uh and
we'll wait for that conclusion before a
final decision is made
gotcha and then one other question just
building off of the earlier
questions about texas does the white
house believe that more
should have happened earlier to better
prepare texas
yeah a decade ago water systems for
climate change
yes um and what does the white house
believe needs to happen
there and in other states going forward
and does the kind of crisis we're seeing
right now make any of those things
more urgent yes a really important
question i think our focus though right
now is on
providing relief to the emergency
situation that we're seeing in texas and
in surrounding states i'm sure there'll
be
time to look back and evaluate what
better preparations if better
preparation should have been done
could be could have been made but at
this point in time we're just focused on
getting relief to the people in the
state and the surrounding states i
should say
great question on going back to the five
days of sure
so again at the end of the day unions
local school officials governors will
have
the ultimate say on this who is the
president
and at the end of the day is he setting
a goal
um that can't that he can't meet and
that is
ultimately not his to me well
you're right in the sense then this kind
of goes back to
one of nancy's earlier questions right
this is going to be up to local schools
and school districts
however what has been lacking is clear
federal guidelines
based on science done by health experts
to
give schools a better understanding or a
better road map
for what mitigation steps they can take
to ensure their teachers their students
their community can return safely that
was what was
announced by the cdc of course on friday
the role that the president can play i'm
not the president i work i'm speaking
for him
the role the president can play is to
work with congress to get the necessary
funding
that is the role he can really play that
is why his focus is on
the american rescue plan working with
congress the role the federal government
can play
is from of course not just providing the
cdc guidelines from the cdc director and
their team
but also having our department of
education work with schools
on figuring out you know how to apply
the uh
the review or the research that is
currently underway
and how to apply the mitigation steps
that will be secretary cardona's
first priority when he takes office but
it will be up to the local school
districts
to determine the implementation of the
mitigation steps
thanks jim thank you everyone thank you
all right there is white house press
secretary
jen saki reapplying a double mask and
exiting
we are going to be taking calls in about
a half hour 20 minutes
for our friday podcast if you want to
participate in that
check the david pakman show twitter for
information on how to participate and
then i will also be back tomorrow at
noon eastern
for the uh gamestop robin hood
hearings which i think are going to be
very very interesting subscribe if
you're watching on youtube
like if you're watching on facebook
follow if you're watching on twitch
and then you'll be notified of future
streams and hope to talk to some of you
guys
uh in about 20 minutes just check this
the show david pakman
show all one word twitter for
information on how to participate in our
live call segment